at point as the North Koreans promise to
take steps toward a complete nuclear
denuclearization the president is before
yeah they've done it multiple times
before and lied about it right and now
we have President Trump saying that he's
going to end joint us-south Korean
military exercises is that a good idea
I don't mind putting these exercises on
hold over the arca time the exercises
won't matter but the one thing I would
object to violently is withdrawing our
forces from South Korea China is trying
to play president Trump through North
Korea China's goal for decades has been
to drive us out of Asia if we withdraw
our forces and that's part of a deal I
can't support the deal that will lead to
more conflict not less our forces in
South Korea are stabilizing for Asia
they're trying to drive us out of Asia
China is and that would be a bad deal so
hope we don't go down that road well
senator I was just there in May with the
8th army and you know what their slogan
is because I know you've been there and
you've served it's ready to fight - not
in there they train all the time so that
they can be ready to defend themselves
and the South Koreans and their families
that live there so what purpose does it
serve ending these training exercises it
gives us breathing space to get it to
get an agreement what we've done we're
not stopping training we're stopping
joint exercises for a while to give kim
jeonggam some assurance that we're
willing to meet him more than halfway I
am willing to do a lot of things to get
them to give up their nuclear weapons
and in their missile program I'm well
you know he can have a membership at
Trump Nationals I really don't care how
generous we are as long as we don't go
too far when it comes to our troop
presence at the end of the day this is
the last best chance to end this
conflict without a war I'm very
open-minded to security agreements into
economic incentives to North Korea but I
am very closed-minded when it comes to
withdraw our forces I realize your